Okay, dann haben wir jetzt also eine Stunde lang geklärt, was man bei Open Source-Software finanzieren kann und muss und dass es eigentlich gar kein großes Problem ist, so was ihr bis jetzt erzählt habt. Da frage ich mich natürlich, wie ist denn das bei GnuPG schiefgegangen? Also fast schiefgegangen. Wir klären das gleich. Wir hören vorhin noch eine kleine Musik von Stony Broder Jr. Let the Jungle Grow. Stony, Broder Jr. Let the Jungle Grow und wir sind natürlich beim Chaosradio und das geht natürlich nicht ohne die passenden Nachrichten dazu, die diesmal präsentiert werden von Fiona.
Die Nerd-News Lenovo hat auf einige Notebook-Serien Ende 2014 die Software Superfish vorinstalliert. Superfish installiert ein eigenes SSL-Root-Zertifikat in Windows. Damit kann Superfish auch eigene Werbung in Webseiten einbauen, die Verschlüsse zwischen Webbrowser und Servern im Internet übertragen werden. Besonders brisant dabei ist, dass sowohl der Private Key als auch dessen Passwort mit der Software ausgeliefert wurden und nun im Internet kursieren. Dadurch ist es sehr einfach, den betroffenen Rechnern gefälschte Websites unterzuschieben. Die verwendete Technologie stammt von der Firma Komodia und findet auch in anderen Produkten Verwendung. Das US-Cert pflegt eine Liste mit solchen kritischen Produkten, die ihr in den Shownotes findet. Der Antivirus-Hersteller Kaspersky hat verdächtigen Code einer bislang unbekannten kriminellen Hackergruppe untersucht. Dabei ist Kaspersky auf Trojaner gestoßen, welche die Firmware von Festplatten infizieren können. Indizien deuten darauf hin, dass die Gruppe, von Kaspersky Equation Group getauft, enge Kontakte zu NSA unterhält. Nach Thunder Strike und Bad USB ist damit Malware für eine weitere PC-Komponente bestätigt, die auch eine Neuinstallation des Betriebssystems übersteht. Der Film Citizen 4 der US-Filmemacherin Laura Poitras ist in der Kategorie beste Reportage mit einem Oscar ausgezeichnet worden. Citizen 4 zeigt den ersten Teil von Edward Snowden's Flucht. Er begleitet den Whistleblower bei seinen ersten Treffen mit Poitras und dem Journalisten Glenn Greenwald in einem Hotel in Hongkong. Doch nicht allen schmeckt der Film. Ein ehemaliger amerikanischer Navy-Offizier strebt ein Gerichtsprozess gegen Poitras und die Produktionsfirma Weinstein Company wegen angeblicher Veröffentlichung von Staatsgeheimnissen an.
Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zur zweiten Hälfte vom Chaos Radio 209, wo es um Open Source-Finanzierung geht, in der Marienstraße 11 im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, wo ihr gerne auch noch vorbeikommen könnt. Und die Sendung fing, nahm eine erstaunliche Wendung. Also es fing ja an mit, es gibt den aktuellen Anlass, GnuPG, eine weit verbreitete Open Source Verschlüsselungssoftware, hatte nicht genug Spenden zusammenbekommen und das ist dann, hat dann doch noch irgendwie geklappt. Aber in dem Zuge gab so eine große Diskussion darum, wie Open Source-Projekte überhaupt finanziert werden können. Wir haben jetzt eine Stunde darüber geredet. Ich habe festgestellt, teuer ist vor allem, dass das erst mal programmiert werden muss, dass es sehr komplex werden kann und dass dieser Code natürlich auch durchgeguckt werden muss. Und dann haben wir eigentlich die ganze Stunde darüber geredet, wie gut das mit der Finanzierung eigentlich funktioniert. Also ja, das Geld kommt dann irgendwie von Firmen, die sich aus verschiedenen Beweggründen an Open Source-Projekten beteiligen. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass sie nicht zu viel machen. Aber letztendlich ist da irgendwie Geld da. Und da frage ich mich natürlich, wenn das alles funktioniert und auch wir gerade von zwei Leuten gehört haben, haben die also wirklich Jobs oder sich zumindest damit finanzieren, was den Lebensunterhalt angeht, indem sie Open Source-Software programmieren. Warum, wie kam es denn zu diesem GnuPG-Problem? Was war denn da los? Gab es da nicht genug Interesse von den Firmen oder was ist da los?
Also aus meiner Sicht ist es so gewesen, dass erstmal, wir haben jetzt hier über viele Sachen gesprochen, in denen das funktioniert. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch viele Unternehmen, die nehmen sich freie Software, benutzen die und haben dafür nie irgendjemand Geld gegeben, sondern nutzen das einfach und das funktioniert.
Das ist ja auch ein gutes Recht jetzt erstmal. Moralisch vielleicht nicht, aber rechtlich auf jeden Fall.
Das ist auch moralisch erstmal okay. Das einzige, was eben die Schwierigkeit ist, ist, wenn jetzt dort ein Problem aufkommt, wer ist dann dafür verantwortlich? Also ich habe eine Infrastruktur und jetzt ist es ja meistens nicht so, wenn ich jetzt ein großes Unternehmen habe, habe ich teilweise jetzt von den großen Internetanbietern, die haben ja auch sehr viele Daten dort, und wenn die jetzt dafür sorgen wollen, dass ihre Software eigentlich sicher ist und dass die Daten bei denen bleiben, dann sollten sie eigentlich gucken, dass sie in ihre Infrastruktur investieren. Also schauen, dass da immer wieder jemand drüber guckt, ist das denn noch sicher, oder gehen dann auf einmal Daten verloren und auf einmal sind meine ganzen Kundendaten von der Versicherung in der Öffentlichkeit. Und da ist es halt in der Vergangenheit jetzt sehr oft so gewesen, dass in solche Komponenten nicht investiert worden ist. Meiner Ansicht nach auch deswegen, weil wenn dort was passiert, also wenn ich ein sicheres Problem habe, dann tut das mir wirtschaftlich nicht besonders weh. Also warum sollte ich in was investieren, was mir nachher wirtschaftlich nicht weh tut?
Ich versuche mal zu sagen, einem konkreten Ausgedachten Beispiele nachzuholen, ob ich dich richtig verstanden habe. Also eine Bank hat Kunden und macht Online-Banking. Sie macht diese Online-Banking mit Open Source-Software. Investiert ihr aber nicht rein, weil die Open-Source-Software funktioniert halt so irgendwie, das passt schon. Dann gibt es ein Problem mit der Open Source-Software, das möglicherweise daraus entstanden ist, weil niemand mehr da rein investiert. Und die Bank sagt dann, oh ja, Online-Banking ist schiefgegangen, das tut uns jetzt echt leid, liebe Kunden, aber das ist euer Problem.
Ja, oder sie haben sogar noch mit dem Finger, wir haben ja hier ein konkretes Beispiel auf Open-SSL-Entwickler gezeigt, dann haben gesagt, diese acht Entwickler, die haben es verbockt. Aber die Bank hat kein einziges Mal einen Cent an die Entwicklung, die Wartung von dieser Software investiert.
Also jetzt sprichst du auf Heartbleed an. Also Sicherheitslücke aus dem letzten Jahr, die das HTTPS, was wir manchmal in unseren Web-Browsern sehen, halt kaputt gemacht hat, das kann man so einfach sagen.
Und da, als das rauskam, ist festgestellt worden, dass es eigentlich für die Verbreitung dieser Software sehr wenig Leute waren, die das Ganze entwickelt haben und das fast keine von den großen Unternehmen, die diese Software in so einem sicherheitskritischen Bereich verwendet, Geld investiert hat, damit die Software auch weiter gewartet wird.
Jetzt könnte man bei SSL sagen, naja gut, das ist tatsächlich so, das könnte man denen auch zum Vorwurf machen, zumindest den moralischen, dass man sagt, wenn ihr das schon benutzt und auch ja eigentlich mit der Sicherheit werbt, die das eurem Produkt verleiht, dann solltet ihr auch mal Geld rein investieren. Hat sich das denn jetzt geändert, bevor wir weitergehen? Ist da seit diesem Fehler was passiert?
Ja, also Hardplate ist ja so ein bisschen der Anstoß von der ganzen Debatte gewesen, wie finanziert man sicherheitskritische, freie Software? Und da gab es dann auch ein paar Unternehmen, die sich zusammengetan haben und Geld in den Topf geworfen haben und gesagt haben, aus dem Topf wollen wir dann Software wieder finanzieren, dass da Audits gemacht werden, dass da Entwickler bezahlt werden, dass sie das weiterentwickeln sollen. Das wollen wir aus dem Topf mitmachen. Das ist jetzt auch der Topf, aus dem auch ein Teil von der GnuPG-Entwicklung weiter mit bezahlt werden soll. Das ist gemacht worden. Wobei, wenn man sich die Beträge dort anschaut und sieht, was für Unternehmen da sind oder welche Unternehmen da auch nicht drin sind und wie viel Geld Unternehmen oft machen, die eigentlich auf unsere Daten aufpassen sollten, dann ist das Peanuts, von wem wir da gerade sprechen. Von daher, das ist ein Anstoß, der ein paar Unternehmen jetzt dazu gebracht hat, dass die Änderungen machen, dass die Geld investieren. Aber es sind sehr wenige Unternehmen, die sich daran im Moment noch beteiligen.
Darf ich da kurz einhaken, es ist nicht immer nur ein Problem des mangelnden Geldes. Wenn bestimmte Projekte sich schon strukturell in eine falsche Richtung entwickelt haben, wird es nicht viel besser, wenn man da Geld hinterher wirft. Das heißt, wenn es eh schon Projektmanagement-Probleme gibt, wie bei OpenSSL zum Beispiel auch lange gesehen. OpenSSL hatte das Problem, dass sie sich haben zertifizieren lassen und mit dieser Zertifizierung einen bestimmten Softwarestand immer wieder weiter verkauft haben an bestimmte Kunden innerhalb eines rechtlichen Konstrukts, den sie an dieses Projekt rangehangen haben. Und hatten am Ende wenig Interesse daran, bestimmte Dinge, die eigentlich moderne Bibliotheken noch mitbringen, sondern heutzutage defensive Programmierung, bestimmte Änderungen an der API einfach nicht mehr reingezogen haben. Sie haben sich aktiv gegen Kontributionen gewährt, die dazugegeben worden sind. Und das Problem kannst du nicht mit Geld lösen.
Naja, also so, wie du es gerade erzählt hast, kann man es schon mit Geld lösen, weil es wäre gar nicht dazu gekommen, wenn immer genug Geld da gewesen wäre, wenn sie es nicht in diesem Stand hätten verkaufen müssen.
Sie sind da ganz gut ausgekommen, erst mal mit ihrem Modell. Das Problem ist, wenn du ein Projekt hast, was irgendwie vor sich hin wurschtelt, dann gibt es immer die Option, ganz viel Geld hinzuwerfen, und zu sagen, wir machen einen Fork. Also wir entwickeln diese Bibliothek unabhängig von den Entwicklern weiter, die das gerade tun. Aber sowas kann man auch machen, ohne dass da Geld hingeworfen wird. Das Open-SSL ist auch wieder ein super Beispiel, weil die OpenBSD-Entwickler dann gesagt haben, wir haben dieses Open-SSL bei uns in einer Codebase, und wir wollen nicht, dass so hässliche Software da drin ist. Und haben dann gesagt, wir machen jetzt einen feindlichen Fork, haben diese Software dann unter dem Namen ReSSL erstmal von diversen alten Zöpfen befreit, haben dort Support für Software. Und das ist alles, ohne dass man Geld investiert, ist das schon passiert. Also es ist ein mehrdimensionales Problem. Man kann sowas mit Geld erschlagen, aber zuweilen muss man das dann auch ohne das Original-Team machen.
Aber es ist nochmal übergeordnet, nehmen wir uns eine Versicherung, die muss sicherstellen, dass unsere Daten zum Beispiel nicht geleakt werden, dass sie nicht rauskommen, dass sie das System nicht verlassen, sondern dass sie dort sicher verwahrt sind. Und wenn es diesem Unternehmen, dieser Versicherung, sehr stark wehtun würde, wirtschaftlich, wenn unsere Daten rausgehen, wenn das eigene System unsicher ist, dann würden die auch mehr Aufwand betreiben, um zu schauen, ist das denn eine Bibliothek, die jetzt mal angenommen unsicher ist und selbst wenn man da mehr Geld drauf wirft, dann wird die nicht sicherer. Dann müssen sie sich trotzdem nach Alternativen umschauen, weil sie haben sehr viel Umsatz, sie haben eine Verantwortung dafür, dass sie das System eigentlich sicher halten. Aber es ist kein wirtschaftlicher Anreiz da, das wirklich umzusetzen. Und das ist meiner Ansicht nach eins von den größten Problemen, dass die Leute, die eigentlich dafür sorgen müssen, also die die Möglichkeit haben, ein System sicher zu machen, nicht die Leute sind, die nachher den Schaden haben, wenn ein System wirklich unsicher ist.
Aber siehst du da quasi den Gesetzgeber in der Pflicht? Oder wie sollte man sowas etablieren?
Also eine Möglichkeit wäre, das gesetzlich zu machen. Es gibt bestimmt auch andere Möglichkeiten. Ich meine, das ist eine Sache, die wir uns jetzt mehr darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Aber ich denke, am wichtigsten ist erst mal, dass man sich bewusst darüber ist, die Leute, die ein System sicherer machen können, sind meistens nicht die, die darunter leiden, wenn es unsicher ist im Moment.
Ich glaube, es ist primär auch jetzt kein Problem, was die Politik lösen muss. Alleine wird sie auch gar nicht können, sondern eher mal wieder ein gesellschaftliches Problem, wo es halt auf der einen Seite Leute gibt, die nur nehmen, und irgendwann sogar eine Entwartungshaltung an Open Source-Projekte entwickeln, im Sinne von, warum habt ihr nicht Funktionalität XY? Macht mal, aber bis morgen und umsonst natürlich, wo so eine kostenlose Kultur dann vorherrscht.
Und es muss auch nicht immer Geld sein.
Also ein Dankeschön oder, wie Erdgeist Freund so schön sagte, mal ein Bier vorbeischecken, das ist oftmals, das motiviert dann viel mehr als die 10 Euro, weil man weiß dann wieder, für wen macht man den ganzen Mist hier.
Na ja gut, aber das Skaliert natürlich auch nicht unendlich. Und wir reden ja heute tatsächlich darüber, wie so eine Projekte finanziert werden können, nicht wie sie sich betrinken können.
Wir haben zusammen. Aber auf der anderen Seite können wir das Ganze auch vom anderen Ende der Skala, nämlich vom Privatnutzer sehen. Wir haben beispielsweise bei OnCloud halt auch für mobile Betriebssysteme Apps in den jeweiligen App-Stores. Die lassen sich halt auch selber im Quellcode kompilieren. Überhaupt kein Thema, jeder kann das. Das ist natürlich praktisch etwas anders. Da haben wir uns dafür entschieden, zu sagen, wer sich das jetzt aus dem App-Store runterlädt. Gerade für Apple gibt es da ja wenig Alternativen zum offiziellen App-Store. Es kostet halt irgendwie 99 Cent, Euro 50. Also nichts, was man nicht für einen Cappuccino morgens auch ausgeben würde oder Nespresso. Und es kommen dann tatsächlich Leute zu uns und sagen, warum muss ich da jetzt Geld für zahlen? Und unsere Argumentation ist immer, wir brauchen auch jemanden, der diese Applikation weiterentwickelt und der möchte gerne auch irgendwie sein Cappuccino kaufen. Und so schließt sich der Kreis. Und das trifft auf komplettes Unverständnis. Also das ist sowohl auf der oberen Ebene mit den Unternehmen, die sagen, wir haben doch diese Bibliothek, die ist doch schön und warum sollten wir? Aber das trifft genauso gut den kleinen Privatanwender, der da wirklich eine sehr einfache, also die App-Stores mögen ja verteufelt werden, wie sie wollen, aber es ist eine sehr einfache Art und Weise einfach demjenigen, der den Programm schreibt, eine kleine Summe zukommen zu lassen. Und dann ist das halt auch wieder zu viel, weil könnte ja auch umsonst sein. Und so trifft es quasi jeden, der da dran mitwirken könnte.
So und jetzt noch mal zurück zu GnuPG. Eine Software, die ja sozusagen tatsächlich eher, also in meinem Kenntnisstand zumindest korrigiert mich, wenn es noch eine andere Anwendungsmöglichkeit gibt, die erstmal von Einzel-Usern benutzt wird, die halt miteinander verschlüsselt kommunizieren wollen. Und die halt tatsächlich auch deutlich mehr.
Also viel von dem Signieren von Software, die du automatisiert runterlädst, passiert über GnuPG. Das heißt, wenn du von irgendeinem Entwickler Software runterlädst und vergleichen möchtest, ob das vom selben Typen digital signiert worden ist, wie als ich das erste Mal die Software installiert habe.
Alle LILU-Distributionen sichern ihre Updates und ihre Softwarepakete über GnuPG ab. Das läuft im Hintergrund, das kriegst du gar nicht mit.
Dann darfst du vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären. Also wenn man ein Update für ein Programm runterlädt, dann lädt man nicht nur einfach die Datei runter, sondern es wird im Hintergrund sozusagen eine verschlüsselte Datei runter oder eine signierte.
Man kann das ganz gut vergleichen mit einer Blombe. Also wenn du eine Software bei dir auf dem Computer installieren willst, dann willst du die Software von dem Entwickler und nicht die von der NSA. Und der Entwickler benutzt GnuPG, um das Ganze zu signieren. Also wie wenn man jetzt so einen Kasten nimmt, dann macht man eine Blombe hin. Und wenn das dann bei mir ankommt, das Paket, dann schaue ich mir das an und prüfe die Signatur und schaue, ist die Blombe noch zu oder hat die schon jemand aufgemacht und dadurch eventuell Änderungen an der Software gemacht.
So, das heißt, es gibt also nicht nur die End-User, die ihre Mails verschütteln, sondern es gibt auch noch Firmen, die ein Interesse haben. Woran ist das denn schief gegangen mit der Finanzierung?
Du sagst, schief gegangen mit der Finanzierung. Also erstmal ist natürlich dieser Zeitungsartikel auch ein wenig sehr Tränendrüse und war glaube ich dem Werner Koch auch unangenehm im Nachhinein, dass das so aufgebrauscht worden ist. Dieses Crowdfunding, was er da ursprünglich angeleitet hat, lief ja schon eine Weile und war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so, dass er ganz dringend jetzt den Lebensunterhalt davon verdienen wollte. Er hat nur gemeint, wenn er jetzt noch mehr Zeit rein investieren will.
Das habe ich ja, als hätte ich Matthias sozusagen schüttelt auf dem Kopf.
Also vielleicht mal kurz die Historie. Also Werner hat damals noch, als das Gnu-Projekt gestartet ist, gab es mal die Überlegung noch, als hat Gnu-Projekt gemeint, wir brauchen noch seine Verschlüsselungssoftware. Und Werner hat sich das angeguckt und hat gedacht, okay, das könnte ich machen. Und hat am Anfang das als Hobbyprojekt mit angefangen. Dann ist das Ganze ein bisschen gewachsen und er hat dann ein Unternehmen gegründet und hat damit Aufträge angenommen, um eben Änderungen zu machen, die andere Leute hatten Wünsche an die Software. Es kam dann auch später dazu noch, dass manche von den Aufträgen, zum Beispiel gerade auch hier von deutschen Ministerien mit kamen, da kam was vom Wirtschaftsministerium, die hatten eine Zeit bestimmte Wünsche an GnuPG. Es gab auch eine Portierung von GnuPG, dass das auch auf Windows funktioniert und da gab es Aufträge für. Da gab es Geld und Werner hat da mit dran gearbeitet, andere Unternehmen haben da auch mit dran gearbeitet. Das war auch jetzt nicht eine Sache, dass nur G10 Co. dass das Unternehmen von Werner an GnuPG entwickelt hat, sondern da waren andere mit drin und haben so Aufträge mit angenommen. Jetzt ist es so gewesen, dass eben das, was wir vorher mit besprochen hatten, wenn jetzt immer mehr Interessen kommen, dann wird sowas komplexer. Da ist jetzt eine Ministerium, die sagt, wir hätten das gerne auf Windows, das andere sagt, aber wir wollen, dass das mit der Software mit funktioniert, wir hätten doch die Funktionalität gerne drin und dann ist das Ganze komplexer geworden. Und wenn man so Funktionen schreibt, dann hat man meistens nicht die Zeit, auch die Wartung zu machen. Jetzt ein anderes Problem, was man teilweise bei so freien Softwareprogrammierung hat oder generell bei Softwareentwicklung hat, ist, Leute, die gut Software schreiben, gute Hacker, sind nicht immer gute Marketingleute, sind nicht immer gute Geschäftsleute. Das heißt, die hacken gerne und lösen gerne ein technisches Problem. Jetzt hat der Werner oft, wenn er hat geschaut, dass er GnuPG-Entwicklung weitermacht und nicht jetzt jemand dafür bezahlt, dass der jetzt tolle Werbebroschüren macht, das den Leuten gibt, damit die wieder Geld geben, damit man weiter finanzieren kann. Und da ist eben auch viel Idealismus drin, dass man braucht Verschlüsselungssoftware und ich entwickle daran. Jetzt gab es eben dann das Problem, dass nicht mehr neue Aufträge reingekommen sind, in dem Umfang, dass man das weiter mehrere Leute davon bezahlen kann. Also eine Zeit lang, als es die Aufträge gab, war G10 Code. Da gab es dann noch einen zweiten Entwickler zum Beispiel, der dafür bezahlt worden ist. Oder auch andere Unternehmen, die da mitgemacht hatten. Und als es dann weggebrochen ist, gab es keine neuen Projekte. Nur ein paar kleinere Sachen, mit denen man sich über Wasser gehalten hat. Und dann war halt Werner irgendwann in der Situation, mache ich so weiter mit dem Einkommen? Kann ich da mit einer Familie finanzieren? Jetzt musste ich schon einen Entwickler entlassen. Wie mache ich weiter? Und eine Überlegung war eben, kann man das vielleicht durch Spenden mitmachen? Die Jahre davor kamen so 5.000 Euro im Jahr zusammen durch GnuPG-Spenden. Dann gab es eine Crowdfunding-Kampagne, da kamen dann 35.000 Euro, glaube ich. Da kamen das Problem mit dazu, dass Crowdfunding, da kommt nicht 35.000 Euro bei Werner Koch für die GnuPG-Entwicklung an, sondern da geht die Plattformgebühr weg für die Crowdfunding-Plattform, da gehen Steuern ab. Und wenn das dann weg ist, dann hast du teilweise noch die Hälfte davon. Und für 15.000 Euro, wie lange kannst du da entwickeln? Kannst du nicht einen Jahresgehalt von einem Entwickler bezahlen?
Soll vorkommen.
Soll vorkommen, sollte aber nicht vorkommen. Und was dann gewesen ist, ist, dass man noch mal einen Spendenaufruf gemacht hatte, der ist dann hier von Warholen Stiftung, FSFE, hat das auch mit verbreitet gehabt, dann ist das auch auf Boing Boing erschienen, da kam dann auch mal was zusammen, das waren dann bis Ende Januar 40.000 Euro kamen da zusammen, seit letztem Dezember. Das war schon mal achtmal so viel, wie sonst im Jahr zusammengekommen sind. Aber wenn man zwei Entwickler bezahlen will, eine Firma unterhalten will, dann sind so 120.000 eher so ein Ziel, was man so verfolgen sollte. Und das ist schon nicht unbedingt der Bestbezahl des Programmierers, wenn man 120.000 Euro zwei Leute von bezahlen will. Jetzt gab es dann eben einen großen Artikel oder einen Artikel, der eine große Auswirkung hatte. Das war ein Artikel auf ProPublica. Der war relativ emotional auch geschrieben, hat so ein bisschen die persönliche Geschichte erzählt, hat da auch manche Sachen vielleicht ein bisschen vereinfacht dargestellt, was, wie hier Erdgeist gerade meinte, Werner auch nachher nicht ganz so angenehm alles war. Aber was das auf jeden Fall gebracht hatte, war, dass das war, nachdem der Artikel erschienen ist, ist innerhalb von 24 Stunden sind 120.000 Euro zusätzlich reingekommen. Mittlerweile, ich habe gerade vorher noch mal geguckt, dass auf der GnuPG-Spendenseite sind 222.000 Euro irgendwas zusammengekommen. Dazu hat die Linux Foundation gesagt, dass sie 60.000 Euro für einen zusätzlichen Entwickler bezahlen wollen, weil sie gemerkt haben, GnuPG ist so unterfinanziert, wir wollen kein zweites Heartbleed, also der Bug, der da letztes Jahr rauskam. Dazu kamen dann Facebook, die gesagt haben, wir wollen 50.000 Dollar spenden. Dann gab es Stripe, die gesagt haben, sie wollen 50.000 Spenden. Und Bauholland hat auch noch Spenden angenommen, die sind auch noch ungefähr 10.000 Euro. Also das ist auf einmal dann zusammengekommen.
Also wir sehen jetzt ja genau das. Dann, wenn der Fokus der Öffentlichkeit drauf fällt, sei es die SSL-Nummer oder jetzt GnuPG, dann lässt sich das auf einmal finanzieren. Aber es ist halt immer Brände löschen. Und es ist genau. Es ist nicht sich mal hinsetzen, sich überlegen, was ist kritische Infrastruktur, die wir in Open Source auch haben wollen. Als Europäer, gerade jetzt mit den ganzen NSL-Geschichten die letzten paar Jahre, will man nicht vielleicht mal eine europäische Open Source Textverarbeitung haben?
Plus an der Stelle muss man auch, wenn die Community jetzt Geld hingegeben hat für den Projektstand, so wie er ist, dieses GnuPG, in dem Zustand, wie es ist. Und es gibt für mich ein bisschen das Problem, es gibt keine Qualitätskontrolle. Da hast du jetzt Geld und wir belohnen dich mal. Wir haben gar nicht reingeguckt, wie die Software gerade aussieht. Und es gibt irgendwie auch nicht wirklich negative Auswirkungen, wenn er ab jetzt das Projekt verkackt. Also es gibt kein übergeordnetes Projektmanagement, was da mal draufguckt. Und in der Vergangenheit hat sich irgendwie bei GnuPG und auch bei OpenSSL gezeigt, dass dort strukturelle Probleme... Für mich ist es ein strukturelles Problem, wenn irgendjemand versucht, eine Firma drumherum aufzumachen mit umklarem Ausgang. Wenn er nicht schon vorfällt, lange genug plant, um zu gucken, wie lange kann ich davon leben und im Zweifel noch irgendwie einen Back-up-Plan haben, dass ich dann nicht irgendwie verarmt dastehe. Wenn man das nicht tut, dann ist es für mich naiv. Und wenn man am Ende das Projekt noch halt mit Geisel nimmt, wie die OpenSSL zum Beispiel, dann ist das für mich unverantwortlich. Also man muss immer schon schauen, dass man nicht Hunger hat. Und man kann nicht am Ende dann sagen, hier ist der Deal, ich mach mal für alles kostenlos, ich lasse mich von Leuten bezahlen für Sonder-Spezial-Features und irgendwann ankommen und sagen, oh jetzt ist mein Geld jetzt alle wirklich so fett zugrunde.
Was du da sagst ist, wenn du Open Source-Entwickler sein willst, dann musst du gefälligst fit genug sein, dir auch noch einen Zweitstopp auf die Beine zu stellen und das Marketing zu machen.
Nein, das ist nicht was ich sage. Man muss im Zweifel das Beveilen, ein Projekt betrachten, für die nächsten fünf Jahre habe ich hier einen Job, weil die Finanzierung ist gesichert, das mache ich als Selbstständiger auch. Ich habe irgendeinen Kunden für die nächsten fünf Jahre und dann ist gut. Aber danach muss ich halt wieder schauen, entweder geht das Projekt weiter oder ich mache etwas anderes und sich einfach so in Abhängigkeit von so einem Projekt zu begeben, ist grundgefährlich und wenn es auch nur kritische Infrastruktur ist, dann ist es für mich verantwortungslos.
Also für mich hat das Ganze mit GnuPG eine Sache ganz extrem gezeigt, das war, dass viele Menschen die Software benutzt haben, ohne sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie das dann finanziert ist.
So weit noch, ohne es zu wissen.
Ja, teilweise ohne zu wissen, dass sie die Software überhaupt drin haben. Das ist ja noch fahrlässiger. Da haben große Unternehmen, die brauchen diese Software, um sicherzustellen, dass sie die richtigen Pakete installieren oder andere Verschlüsselungstätigkeiten damit zu machen, Daten zu verschlüsseln und wissen nicht mal, dass sie davon abhängig sind. Jetzt haben sie auf einmal durch den Artikel mitgemerkt, da ist eine Software, die haben wir bei uns auch drin. Das ist ja vor uns ganz wichtig. Da kann es jetzt sein, dass der das nicht mehr weitermacht. Dann merkt man auf einmal, dass das, was ich die ganze Zeit kostenlos genommen habe, was ich für, ich atme mal Luft ein, ist die ganze Zeit da. Das sollte ich vielleicht was für bezahlen. Das war für mich die eine Lehre, die ich daraus gezogen habe, dass viele Unternehmen und auch viele Privatpersonen Software einfach nutzen, ohne sich Gedanken zu machen, wie die eigentlich entsteht. Der zweite Punkt war, was du gemeint hast, dass du erwartest, dass wenn jemand freie Software schreibt, dass der auch ein guter Geschäftsmann ist. Das ist eben der Punkt, den ich gemeint habe. Es gibt Entwickler, die sind nicht so die...
Ich glaube, darf ich das mal ganz kurz erklären?
Entschuldigt, Leute, aber jetzt wird gerade ein bisschen langer. Matthias, sag doch mal bitte zu Ende.
Also es gibt Entwickler, die sind nicht so die guten Geschäftsleute. Das sind Leute, die wollen einfach gute Software schreiben. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass es halt oft nicht so funktioniert, weil teilweise, wenn ich extrem gutes Marketing habe, aber eine schlechte Software, dann verdiene ich teilweise mehr Geld, wie wenn ich gute Software schreibe, aber kein Marketing mache.
Und das sind ja nicht die einzigen Achsen. Du hast ja Projektmanagement, du hast viele andere Dinge, die dann noch mit reinspielen, die du als einfacher, in meinem Keller entwickler halt, wie auch dann grundsätzlich falsch machst. Und ich denke eher, dass wenn so eine Foundation Geld einsammelt, dann sollte sie, genauso wie sie Programmierer dahinstellt, Leute mit Projektmanagement-Erfahrung einfach auch mitbezahlen. Sagen, dieses Projekt brauchte offensichtlich Hilfe, struktureller Natur, und ich muss am Ende auch den Daumen drauf haben, wenn ich einen Programmierer bezahle, dass ich dem immer noch sagen kann, nee, so geht das nicht, und im Zweifel bist du gefeuert. Und genau diese Keule muss man auch haben und nicht einfach un-gesehen Geld dahinter werfen. Und das ist, glaube ich, der unterschätzte Faktor, dass einfach nur un-gesehenen Spenden einsammeln und sagen, okay, hier nimm mal, macht die Software nicht besser, sondern muss dann auch in dem Moment, wo die Community Geld einsammelt und in die Richtung Projekt wirft, dafür sorgen, dass dieses Geld verantwortungsbewusst eingesetzt wird.
Also dann habe ich jetzt zu sagen, nachdem es nach einer Stunde Sendung ganz gut aussah, sieht es nach einer halben Stunde Sendung wieder ganz bitter aus, nämlich entweder es kommt nur das Geld von großen Firmen oder es kommt von der Community, aber es ist dann irgendwie auch nicht richtig. Wir werden die letzte halbe Stunde dann gleich mal nutzen, um vielleicht ein zumindest potenziell tragfähiges Modell für Open-Source-Software-Finanzierung zu entwerfen. Vorher noch eine kleine Musik, die auch eingesandt wurde, aufgrund des Wunsches eine neue Openermusik fürs Chaos-Radio vielleicht zu haben. Die kommt von Tobias Sensing und er hat hier keinen Namen gegeben, aber wir hören mal kurz rein. So, letzte halbe Stunde im Chaos-Radio 209 über Open-Source-Finanzierung in der Marienstrasse 11. Falls ihr jetzt auch schnell vorbeikommen wollt, könnt ihr es gerne machen, hier in Berlin Erdgeistin da, Lasse, Matthias Kirschner von der FSFE. Yes, fehlerfrei gesagt und Danimo. Und es geht heute abends so ein bisschen hin und her. Also während es sich am Anfang der Sendung einhatte so, ja, mit der Open-Source-Finanzierung ist jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem, weil da gibt es immer Firmen, die irgendwie Geld reinwerfen. Da hatten wir dann festgestellt, naja, es gibt doch so ein kleines Problem, weil halt so Projekte wie OpenSSL und GnuPG haben halt nicht so viel Geld und werden dann immer so gelöscht mit großen Haufen, die dann über ihn ausgekippt werden, wenn es mal dringend wird. Aber dann ist auch das nicht ganz unproblematisch, meint der Erdgeist zumindest dann, weil dann, sagen große Batzen Geld, irgendwo hingeworfen werden, wo man dann gar nicht mehr so genau weiß, ist das dann alles eine Richtigkeit. Was braucht es denn in Zukunft? Vielleicht schaffen wir das in einer halben Stunde noch mal eben die Welt zu retten. Um Open Source-Software nicht nur nachhaltig zu finanzieren, sondern dann auch dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Finanzierung sinnvoll angewendet wird.
Eine Art Zwischeninstanz eigentlich. So was wie die Free Software Foundation, dass man lieber der, der das Geld zum Beispiel jetzt gibt, und die dann dafür gerade stehen, dass so etwas wie eine sichere E-Mail-Verschlüsselung entwickelt wird. Ob sie das Geld dann an GnuPG zum Schluss geben und es dort entwickelt wird, das steht ja auf einer ganz anderen Karte. Einfach ist nicht projektgebunden wegzugeben, sondern wirklich eher eine Agenda haben, was wollen wir als Open Source-Software vorliegen haben. Und dann ist so etwas wie die Open Source Foundation dazu da, dass das nach und nach schrittweise umgesetzt wird.
Eigentlich wäre auch so was noch mal eine Idee für einen Staat, dass der dahergeht und sagt, wir meinen das jetzt mal ernst, wir gucken, welche Komponenten sind denn gerade kritisch, was können wir machen, was kostet uns das. Und dann kann man auch ein bisschen kompetitiv vielleicht mal ausschreiben, sagen, schickt mal ein paar Lösungen ein. Grundvoraussetzungen sind, ihr werdet bezahlt, aber danach ist es irgendwie Open Source, wie unter einer Lizenz, die wir ansagen, und darf jeder benutzen. Und derjenige, der im besten Stück Software in einem unabhängigen Ordet von vielleicht noch anderen Leuten, die sich da bewerben, gewinnt, der bekommt noch einen Bonus dazu und den nächsten Auftrag auch noch.
Und die Hintertür gibt es umsonst dazu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, so einen Start, sich kritische Software entwickeln zu lassen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Nicht den Start entwickeln lassen. Du kannst einfach einen Auftrag geben, dass so unterschiedliche Buden das machen. Und dann, es gibt da Mittel und Wege, dort einfach wenig Geld. Es reicht dann wenig Geld für abgeschlossene Projekte, die vorher klar definiert werden. Und wenn es Open Source ist, kann natürlich jeder reingucken. Wie willst du das Hintertür reingucken?
Also darüber möchte ich dann gleich noch mal vielleicht in 10 Minuten sprechen, da muss man immer reingucken. Das muss halt auch jemand machen. Das ist ja noch mal ein zweites Problem. Aber gibt es noch andere Vorschläge zur nachhaltigen Finanzierung?
Also für mich ist das ein mehrschichtiges Modell. Das eine ist, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man Organisationen hat, an denen man das bündelt, wie zum Beispiel irgendwelchen Stiftungen, Vereine, an die man Geld geben kann als Privatperson oder auch an die Unternehmen Geld geben können, die dann das Geld wieder verteilen und die dann auch dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Interessen durchgesetzt werden. Das haben wir ja auch schon in freier Software, haben wir solche Stiftungen und Vereine. Wir haben zum Beispiel die Free Software Foundation in den USA, die macht viel freie Softwareentwicklung mit dem Gnu-Projekt und hat da eine Agenda, macht ein Projektmanagement und setzt dort ihre Interessen mit durch. Und wenn man da Geld gibt, dann weiß man, okay, das geht in den Zielen lang. Da gibt es in Deutschland, da haben wir zum Beispiel auch so etwas wie KDE-EV, was Daniel ja auch mit hier kennt. Und da kann man auch Geld mit hinbezahlen und die fördern sowas auch. Das ist aber nur ein Aspekt. Der andere ist eben, dass Unternehmen auch selbst, wenn sie bestimmte Interessen haben, dafür bezahlen müssen, dass diese Software mitentwickelt wird. Und da finde ich, das ist einer von den Aspekten, die eben lange Zeit überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt worden ist. Die Unternehmen haben sich nicht angeguckt, was für Software habe ich, was für Software bräuchte ich und wie investiere ich die. Wir haben die nächste Schicht, das ist der Staat. Der Staat hat auch eine Infrastruktur und hat meiner Ansicht nach eine Verantwortung, dass er diese Infrastruktur sicher hält, dass er die wartet und dafür muss er auch Geld bezahlen. Ich will aber eigentlich nicht, dass eine von denen die alleinige Lösung ist, mit der wir das machen. Ich will nicht, dass es nur Unternehmen sind. Ich will nicht, dass es nur Stiftungen und andere Non-Profit sind. Ich will nicht, dass es nur der Staat ist. Ich will, dass alle Leute gemeinsam das lösen. Das ist unsere Infrastruktur, an der wir gemeinsam entwickeln müssen.
Nein, oder auch gegeneinander, auch gesunde Konkurrenz einfach fördern.
Genau, genau. Deswegen fände ich auch so Vorschläge, mich ehrt das, wenn jemand sagt, die FSFE soll das machen und wir wollen der FSFE Geld geben und spenden und die soll das dann machen. Aber das ist eigentlich eine Aufgabe, die ich gar nicht haben will als FSFE. Das ist etwas, ich will nicht entscheiden, was ist denn jetzt gerade das Wichtigste in Freier Software? Ich will, dass mehrere Leute das entscheiden, dass Privatleute sagen, das ist ein nettes Projekt, denen gebe ich Geld, da will ich mal schauen, was da passiert, da investiere ich mal was rein. Und bei manchen Projekten ist das ja auch für Privatsoftware, da sind das eben die 5 Euro für die App, die auch mal mit entscheiden, ob eine Software weiterentwickelt wird oder nicht, wenn das entsprechend Leute machen. Und genauso ist es dann eben für Unternehmen, da sind das halt andere Beträge, da sind das halt eher, wir geben 10.000 Euro und bezahlen das, die anderen bezahlen halt 100.000 Euro und dann wird sowas mitgemacht. Aber es muss von vielen Leuten gemacht werden und wir müssen schauen, dass wir konkurrierende Lösungen auch haben, wo wir einfach gucken, was wird denn besser? Was ist denn der bessere Ansatz?
Der Staat gibt ja eh gerade raue Mengen Geld für Close Source. Guck dir den Staat, Strojaner. Wurde für den Staat entwickelt, was für ein Schrott da rausgekommen ist, hast du dann gesehen. Also dort gibt es auch Optimierungspotenzial, wo ich irgendwie mal sagen würde, dass man das mit einem Schwung mal angehen kann.
Okay, ich zusammengefasst, also Erdgeissprecher des CCC fordert Open Source-Finanzierung des neuen Strojaners.
Nein, eher andersrum. Lieber in Open Source als in Close Source-Projekte, die dann verkackt werden.
Es ist also kurz zusammengefasst, das ist auch unsere Forderung, dass öffentlich finanzierte Software, Software, die von öffentlichem Geld finanziert wird, die muss freie Software sein. Alles, was neu entwickelt wird, muss als freies Software veröffentlicht werden. Weil dann haben andere Unternehmen auch die Möglichkeit, auf Basis davon wieder andere Lösungen zu entwickeln, Forks zu machen, konkurrieren gegen das eine Unternehmen, was vielleicht am Anfang den Auftrag gegeben hat. Und das ist was, was durchweg eigentlich von der Verantwortung von dem Staat ist, dass Software, die mit Steuergeld finanziert worden ist, auch in der Forschung, ob das die App ist, die das Ministerium macht oder eben irgendwelche neuen Aufträge für Sonderanfällung, das muss als freie Software veröffentlicht werden.
Und würde auch nochmal ganz anders Vertrauen geben in so Software, die zum Beispiel im Zensus eingesetzt wurde, weil man in dem Moment auch wirklich gucken könnte, was macht die Software und all diese Verdächtigungen, die überwachen uns und man weiß es halt nicht, wenn man nicht reingucken kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen jetzt noch ein Thema, was dann immer noch ansteht, diese Open Source-Software, da kann ja jeder reingucken, das wird ja nicht gemacht, da war ja Hardbit auch ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür.
Aber das ist dann irgendwie eine Frage wirklich, das Geld ist, weil Audits sind öde. Also Audits ist meistens ziemlich schwer, Leute dazu zu bekommen, sich fremder Leute wohlriechenden Code anzugucken und Anmerkungen zu machen. Das ist echt deutlich schwieriger, Leute dazu zu bekommen, als mal eben irgendwas dazu zu geben, was man leichter sieht. Also eine Übersetzung oder ein nettes Logo machen oder eine Grafik oder ein bisschen Code dazu führen. Leute sind immer mehr so, lieber was Neues schaffen, als irgendwie all das zu maintainen. Ich glaube, in die Maintenance und Audits punktuell mehr Geld reinzustecken, als in die Weiterentwicklung, wäre für mich der richtige Ansatz.
Aber wo wir gerade von diesem gesunden Wettbewerb von verschiedenen Entitäten, die halt Geld haben, reden, dann wäre es doch zum Beispiel die Zielsetzung einer Stiftung zu sagen, okay, der Staat hat jetzt eine Software, die Open Source dann wäre, die jetzt irgendwie ein Zensus oder irgendeine kritische Infrastruktur ist, na die ist Open Source, dann gucken wir uns die doch mal an. Das ist unsere Aufgabe als Foundation, die wir jetzt mal wegen den Staat überwachen. Solche Organisationen gibt es ja bereits und das würde man dann halt nur auf technischer Ebene tun. Und wir zertifizieren jeden Mist, wie weit mein Monitor von meinem Schreibtisch wegsteht, wie weit die Tastatur, überall gibt es DIN und ISO-Normen, warum eben nicht dann auch für Software und es darf halt dann auf staatlicher Seite nur Software eingesetzt werden, die mindestens von zwei unabhängigen Parteien auditiert wurde zum Beispiel oder was auch immer.
Na oder man schickt irgendwie mal Studenten dahin, also es gibt halt blöderweise diese Freiheit der Forschung an den Universitäten, aber man könnte ja einfach mal einen verpflichtenden Uni-Schein machen für du musst mindestens ein Open Source Projekt so nach allen Regeln der Kunst auditiert haben und dafür gibst du dann ein Schein und ohne das kriegst du dein Studium nicht.
Allerdings muss man auch sagen, sehr viele Unis, die wirklich Reputationen haben in Sachen Software-Sicherheit Leute auszubilden, machen das ja schon als Hausaufgabe. Also das ist ja nicht und das ist nur zu selten, aber es ist durchaus etwas, was einem als Uni Vorteile bringen kann.
Ich würde irgendwie auch weitergehen bei Gestaltungshochschulen oder Kunsthochschulen sagen, so mindestens ein Open Source-Projekt mal im UI begleiten, die schlimmsten Scharten auszuwetzen und zu sagen, du brauchst einen Pflichtschein für schnapp dir irgendein Goethe-Tool Open Source und schreib den Entwicklern oder entwickel ein Logo und schreib den Entwicklern, was sie falsch gemacht haben.
Geisteswissenschaftler können Doku schreiben, Quellcode, Kommentare anpassen.
Das ist ja eine schöne Idee, aber für wie wahrscheinlich haltet ihr das?
Null.
Steht da tropf, na klar. Dass das geht, einfach weiter ningeln, na gut. Also die Hochschulprofessoren sind zuweilen ein wenig eigen und in den ganzen Kommissionen, die das beschließen könnten, sitzen auch eher Geisteswissenschaftler als Informatiker. Ich sag steht da tropf, nöhlt den Stein, wenn die Leute groß geworden sind mit Open-Source-Software, werden sie vielleicht in der nächsten Generation das einsehen haben?
Ich finde, das sind alles schöne Ideen, dass man das macht an Universitäten. Ich glaube, was man sich bewusst sein muss, der Effekt wirklich, dass man jetzt eine Software, die man von Studenten auditieren lässt, dass die jetzt dadurch sicherer wird, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das funktioniert. Also Software auditieren ist jetzt auch nicht ganz so einfach. Da braucht man ja auch Erfahrung, damit man das gut machen kann. Und da weiß ich nicht genau, wie da der Effekt ist. Aber ich denke trotzdem, dass das sowas eine sehr gute Idee ist, weil wenn Studenten sowas lernen, wie man andere Software auditiert, dann lernt man viel. Da lernt man erst mal, dass man selber gute Dokumentation für seinen Quellquot schreibt, dass man selber sauber programmiert. Da lernt man auch, dass Sicherheit ein Faktor ist, den man berücksichtigen sollte, wenn man Software schreibt. Und ich glaube, der Effekt ist noch mal viel, viel größer als der Effekt, bringt das wirklich der Software, was die da jetzt in dem Projekt mit angeguckt haben.
Und du setzt natürlich das Basislevel hoch. Also es gibt ja sehr viele Software, die nicht einmal einem Erstsemestler, der wirklich determiniert ist, da mal dran zu gehen, standhält. Und da setzt man ja erstmal ein ganz neues Basislevel, also dessen muss man sich halt auch klar sein.
Wobei es trotzdem zu unserer Frage, wie finanzieren wir freie Software, ist es halt ein Aspekt, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir ermutigen Studenten dazu, dass die solche Projekte mitmachen und verbessern dadurch die Qualität in Zukunft von unserer freien Software.
Wir können ja die Frage ein bisschen größer machen, wie finanziert man das hin, wie unterstützt man das, ohne immer Geld in die Hand nehmen zu müssen?
Na ja, Finanzierung sozusagen schon im Sinne von möglich machen und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sozusagen, das hört sich zumindest jetzt auch gerade so an, dass die, wenn über Open-Source-Software gesprochen wird, dass es tatsächlich bei der Produktion meistens endet. Also die, also ich stelle es mir so vor, sobald es funktioniert, guckt dann keiner mehr so richtig drauf, also in die tieferen Ebenen und Eingeweide machen.
Genau, also unser Produkt ist seit 2001 am Start, ohne ausführliche Tests, verschiedenste Art von Testing, würde es das schon lange nicht mehr geben.
Na ja klar, aber der ganze Lebenszyklus drum rum, den du hast, der ist riesig.
So und ich will, also genau eigentlich geht es mehr darum, gar nicht die eine Quelle jetzt zu benennen und so muss es funktionieren, sondern genau ein Kulturproblem ist. Es muss von allen Seiten was passieren und wenn meine Firma seit Jahrzehnten Geld damit verdient, in Webprojekte zu machen, wo immer ein Apache-Webserver eingesetzt wird, dann kann man auch mal irgendwann, wenn man damit seine Millionen verdient hat, ein bisschen was zurückgeben, muss auch nicht immer Geld sein, kann auch Alkohol sein.
Und ich finde, es ist nicht nur, ich kann was zurückgeben, sondern ich finde, wir müssen die dazu bringen, dass sie das wirklich machen müssen. Also dass sie das einfach, dass die wirtschaftlichen Anreize so sind, dass sie das machen müssen. Dass wenn die ihre Daten verlieren, oder wenn die ihre Daten, also unsere Daten verlieren, dass es nicht uns mehr wehtut als denen.
Ich sehe, dass es noch ein Problem, wirklich was ich mit Kulturproblemen meine, ist, dass es auch sozial innerhalb der Communities gut ablaufen muss. Also man sieht die Linux-Community ist ja oft in der Kritik, dass dort ein sehr harscher Umgangston herrscht, der vielleicht auch bestimmte potenzielle Mithelfer mit bestimmten Skillsets auch abschreckt und das sieht man in vielen anderen Projekten, wo eben verschrobene Charaktere zusammenkommen, funktioniert es schlechter als in anderen Projekten, wo vielleicht die Community offenherziger ist und wo dann nicht die allerbesten Leute da mitmachen, aber irgendwie auch die Masse es da am Ende macht, dann viele Augen, wo wirklich dann viele Augen auf den Code gucken, die zwar alle nicht die allerbesten sind, aber in der Summe dann auch schon ein cooles Ergebnis abliefern.
Aber wie soll so ein Kulturwandel dann vonstatten gehen, also wodurch kann der ausgelöst werden?
Indem man das vorlebt, wie coole Communities funktionieren. Das ist natürlich auch mal entspannter, in schönen Communities sich zu treffen, zum Bier irgendwo zu einer Konferenz zusammenzukommen, irgendwie gemeinsame Interessen auch zu verfolgen als ständig in Kleinkriegen gegen anderen Programmierern seine Lieblingsideen zu beschützen vor Veränderungen. Das sieht man in einigen Projekten, wo die Leute auch Bug Reports als persönlichen Angriff werten oder so Patches, die reinkommen, ist halt…
Das hört sich jetzt an, also wenn ich jetzt Nutzer am neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgerät bin und diese Folge gehört habe, Chaos Radio, dann denke ich so, puh, das ist ja alles ganz schön kompliziert, ich lass die mal lieber machen. Also weil die Entwickler unter sich und dann haben die dann auch irgendwie sozialen Umgangsprobleme und das mit dem Geld weiß ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr, ob ich jetzt spenden darf oder nicht. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Es gibt viele Communities, in denen das funktioniert und es gibt einige Ausgewählte, die dann immer platzen, weil es nicht funktioniert. Und die meisten, guck dir irgendwie Open Source-Projekte an, du benutzt selber Transmission, du benutzt so ein BitTorrent-Programm oder du benutzt ein Java-Programm, so Adium, was von vielen Freiwilligen mitgepflegt wird, die dann auch einfach einer setzt sich hin, macht eine Übersetzung ins Koreanische. So hat er einen Abend für Arbeit und dann ist seine Kontribution, wird reingenommen und er ist froh, dass er damit helfen konnte.
Und das funktioniert immer im Kleinen und wenn die Community toll ist und war nicht der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, sondern der Punkt, den ich machen wollte ist, dass ich als jemand, der überhaupt gar nichts mit diesem ganzen Ding zu tun hat, also nichts, ich bin wirklich nur Benutzer, was kann ich jetzt tun? Also ich hätte nach dieser Sendung den Eindruck, ich darf eigentlich jetzt nichts anfassen, weil egal was ich mache, es ist falsch.
Nee, genau andersrum. Geld ist immer gut, ohne jede Frage.
Da wird es nicht mehr an wen?
Na Free Software Foundation, wir haben gerade einige Sachen gelandet, die...
Da hat er gerade gesagt, er will nicht.
Manchmal gibt es aber nicht...
So war das vorhin von, das war missverständlich vielleicht, ich meinte das vorhin auf den ganz konkreten Fall GnuPG und jetzt nicht alle Open Source-Entwicklungen der Welt wird über die Free Software Foundation, sondern eher, dass die Free Software Foundation eine Patenschaft für ein Projekt übernehmen könnte, zum Beispiel. Aber genauso hilft es eben weiter, mal dir fällt ein Rechtschreibfehler auf der Homepage auf. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir einen Bug bekommen, oder wenn uns jemand darauf aufmerksam macht, da ist ein Rechtschreibfehler, das kann man im Englischen nicht so sagen, oder er übersetzt uns unsere Webseite in Zebräische, ich glaube, da kann man eher, man muss kein Programmierer sein, um in Open Source-Projekten zu helfen. Weil da gibt es an allen Ecken und Enden Arbeit.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall, die meisten freien Software-Projekte freuen sich, wenn Leute mitmachen wollen. Es gibt auch welche, die sagen, will ich nicht, ist mir zu viel Arbeit, das möchte ich nicht. Da gibt es, wie gesagt, viele Möglichkeiten, man kann Sachen Korrektur lesen, man kann Sachen bewerten, übersetzen, all die Möglichkeiten. Aber wenn wir über die Finanzierung sprechen, ist für mich Geld wirklich ein entscheidender Faktor. Das ist ein entscheidender Faktor, der dazu mit beiträgt, dass Software, die für uns entwickelt wird, nicht in der Freizeit entwickelt wird, sondern dass die professionell in dem Hauptberuf mitentwickelt wird. Und manche Software, die wir brauchen, die ist so komplex, die können wir nicht abends mal kurz zwei Stunden entwickeln. Sondern das ist was, da müssen wir langfristig dran arbeiten. Und das ist für mich eine Sache, dass man, wenn man schaut, was für Software man verwendet, dass man dort auch einen Geldstrom zurückbringt. Also wenn ich auf meinem Computer, ich habe eine Mozilla Firefox, ich habe einen VLC, ich habe einen LibreOffice, ich habe einen Inkscape, ich habe einen Skribus oder sonst irgendwas, was auch immer ich da verwende. Warum bezahle ich für die Software kein Geld und gebe da nichts zurück, aber für die Software, die mir die Rechte wegnimmt, die mir vielleicht meine Daten klaut, ohne dass ich das weiß, weil ich die nicht überprüfen kann, weil das unfreie Software ist und niemand reingucken kann, was die eigentlich macht. Da steht ein Preis drauf, da bezahle ich was und das andere bekomme ich nicht hin. Und ich meine, das ist natürlich eine Sache, ist die Einstellung, dass manche Leute sagen, warum soll ich was bezahlen, was umsonst ist. Die andere Sache ist, wir sind einfach im Moment nicht in einem Stadium, dass das einfach ist, Geld zu geben. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wir bei den Apps gelernt haben. In einem App-Store ist es einfach, Geld zu geben. Da kann ich mal kurz einen Euro geben. Aber bei anderen Software ist es oft schwer oder die Projekte machen es noch schwer. Also früher, wenn man auf der LibreOffice-Seite gesucht hat, wie man spenden kann, das war echt schwer. Nachdem die das geändert haben, das war direkt auf der Download-Seite, kommt das noch drauf, haben die auf einmal sehr, sehr viel Geld eingenommen durch Spenden. Einfach, weil sie es prominent gezeigt haben. Und ich finde, das ist legitim für jedes freie Software-Projekt, für jeden freien Software-Programmierer, dass er die Möglichkeit, ihn finanziell zu unterstützen, auch prominent bewirbt. Es gibt natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch Leute, die sagen, ich will gar kein Geld, motiviert mich anders. Dann muss ich schauen, dass ich dem Projekt das anders gebe. Also wir hatten erst hier am 14.2. da machen wir jedes Jahr den I Love Free Software Day, wo wir sagen, motiviert Leute, sagt denen Dankeschön für das, was ihr von denen bekommt. Schreibt einen von den Projekten, danke für eure Arbeit. Heute nerfe ich nicht mit Bugreports, heute nerfe ich nicht mit neuen Feature-Requests, heute sage ich einfach mal Dankeschön, dass du diese Software gemacht hast.
Das wird wirklich gelesen?
Ja, das wird gelesen und die Rückmeldung, die wir von Entwicklern bekommen, ist auch, dass die sich darüber freuen.
Definitiv. Und das Einzige, was mir jetzt noch einfällt, ganz spontan ist, dass es möglicherweise gerade für die Leute, die jetzt eher kein Projekt im Rücken haben, sondern das eher privat machen, aber eher auch gerne mehr draus machen würden. Da habe ich jetzt letztens ein paar innovative Ideen gesehen. Es gibt so Initiativen wie Patreon, wo man sich Patronen für seine Arbeit, die einen monatlich mit einem Betrag x bestützen. Da gibt es also auch Softwareentwickler, die sowas machen. Aber unabhängig jetzt von einer konkreten Lösung, was möglicherweise auch etwas wie die FSFE machen könnte, fühle ich mich jetzt gerade spontan ein, vielleicht macht er das auch schon, ist ganz konkret Leuten auch Hinweise geben und den Tipps geben, wie sie mit solchen Spenden umgehen können, gerade auch in steuerlicher Hinsicht etc. pp. Weil ich glaube, das ist eine ganz starke Hürde, sobald ich irgendwie Geld einnehme, muss ich mit dem Finanzamt machen, wenn ich ansonsten angestellt bin, wo ich bisher überhaupt nichts mit zu tun hatte unter Umständen, maximal wenn ich mir Steuern zurückhören wollte. Plötzlich bin ich in einer ganz anderen Verantwortung, die ich eigentlich gar nicht haben will, weil ich will ja nur irgendwie zusehen, dass ich ein paar Stunden von meiner Arbeit vielleicht dann dem Softwareprojekt durch diese Spenden zukommen lassen möchte. Also dass man das da praktisch für die Leute, die eben eher kotversessen sind und den ganzen Infrastrukturkram nicht haben möchten, denen Hilfe zukommen lässt.
Also um das nochmal so zusammenzufassen, was teilweise passiert ist, dass Menschen Geld geben in der Entwicklung, der sagt, oh mein Gott, du machst mir gerade, das ist ein Problem für mich. Also ich muss jetzt überlegen, wie mache ich das mit der Steuer? Ich muss zum Steuerberater gehen, um zu gucken, was mache ich denn mit den 5000 Euro, die ich jetzt da gekriegt habe? Ich habe ja eigentlich einen Shop, ich bin Angestellter.
Also es gibt auf gar keinen Fall Geld für ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Nein, wenn jemand dir die Möglichkeit anbietet, dann hat er sich das meistens überlegt. Aber es gibt für die Fälle, müssen wir Lösungen finden, bei denen es möglich ist, dass man an einer Stelle Geld geben kann, damit diese Stelle wieder zum Beispiel den Server bezahlt, die Bandbreite bezahlt, zum Beispiel Reisekosten bezahlen kann für Entwickler, damit die sich treffen können. Solche Dinge, die für Entwickler, die noch nicht den Schritt gemacht haben, von Hobby-Programmierer zu Vollzeitangestellt.
Ganz wichtig, es gibt für einige Projekte, gibt es so Projektwunschlisten, wo sie sagen, hier die und die, die Hardware würde uns gerade ganz gut tun, da könnte man Treiber für entwickeln. Oder das und das, wie brauchen wir an Server, bitte besser kein Geld, aber Free Hosting irgendwo wäre total cool, das einfach mal drauf gucken, vielleicht hat man ja noch die Hardware im Keller liegen oder die extra Mega-Bitte noch frei auf seinem Server, dass man das anbieten kann.
Okay, also um das sozusagen kurz zusammenzufassen, möglichst einfach und hoffentlich trotzdem richtig. Wer auch immer Open Source Software benutzt, sich einfach mal Gedanken drum machen, wer da was dahinter steckt, also sich vielleicht mal die Crizes durchlesen, auf die Webseite gehen und gucken, was man den Leuten Gutes tun kann. Das sozusagen, also habe ich jetzt gerade den Eindruck, ist für den normalen User zumindest etwas Kleines, was er machen kann, was aber für den Entwickler schon viel Wert ist und die großen finanziellen Probleme, das ist eigentlich eher sowas, was in der Community und auch innerhalb der Firmen geklärt wird, also was eher tatsächlich ein politisches Anliegen auch ist, von der Größe her gesehen zumindest.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine Hausaufgabe, die wir jetzt mitbekommen haben, dass wir uns überlegen müssen, wie können wir langfristig Finanzierung für freie Software auf die Beine stellen.
Und auch die Projekte selber, wir hatten ganz oft das Problem, die Unis zum Beispiel wollten uns gerne Geld geben, die dürfen aber weder Geld spenden noch für Service und Support aufgeben. Die wollten gerne einen Preis zahlen, die wollten gerne uns 5000 Euro für eine Software exzipsen, dann zahlen die aber umsonst das, was dann wirklich ein jahrelanges Problem war, bis man irgendwann gesagt hat, gut, dann kleben wir trotzdem ein Preisschild drauf, ihr könnt euch natürlich auch umsonst runterladen.
Es kommt dazu Verwirrung. Wir müssen zum Schluss kommen, ich würde gerne von euch noch ganz am Ende wissen, was ist die nächste Software, die finanziell in Probleme kommen wird? Gibt es da schon einen Tipp? Oder ist jetzt erstmal alles geklärt? Betretenes Schweigen.
Das sind so viele, die wir jetzt da denken.
Na gut.
Aber wir hatten ganz kurz, wahrscheinlich sind es die Bibliotheken, die wir jetzt gar nicht im Fokus haben, weil sie nicht direkt sicherheitskritisch sind. So eine Lip-Set ist immer ein guter Kandidat, also so Zippen, Kleinigkeiten etc.
Lip-Tapel vielleicht.
Hausaufgabe an Danimo und Erdgeist, bitte für die Show notes noch heraus suchen, was das bedeutet, was ihr gerade gesagt habt, damit die Leute, die das jetzt noch verstehen wollen, das auch nachlesen können. Das war das Chaos-Radio 209, Finanzierung von der Open Source Software. Wir haben das Problem zumindest angerissen, wenn auch nicht ganz geklärt. Vielen Dank Erdgeist, Lasse, Matthias Kirschner von der FSFE und Danimo. Und ihr könnt diese Folge bestimmt auch bald runterladen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich habe versucht, euch durch die Sendung zu führen und habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.